Louis J gomez let's bring in Damian
Lebanese outside we thought it was 1021
apparently was ten o'clock promoting a
season three of comedy knockout have you
done it Louis yeah I think I can do a
really fun show they're really really
funny feel way better than @midnight
forget all the love and comedy knockouts
a better version of that show what up
kid nice campaign I see you all over the
[ __ ] place man is your subway and
everywhere that's racist how does it
feel to have to see yourself on a
billboard it's interesting it's
flattering it feels good you know they
spent some money no but I mean it it's
cool it's cool it's cool
does your self-esteem get like I know my
self-esteem whenever I get praised or I
have promotion I'm like I'm gonna ruin
it I don't deserve it or you comfortable
with it I'll get in there and surrender
to the momentum of it you don't know me
but I'm kind of like you I'm like
waiting for somebody to face my [ __ ] you
know or I don't want to go find a hole
to crawl in and be like just tell me
when the praises yes this is gonna [ __ ]
up I feel weird sometimes just on the
train when it's all over the trailer to
catch like yo it's going on that's why
you want to trade it don't make it
doesn't compute some time yeah because
that that thing like it the the first
time your face is on the train
you're still gonna be taking the train
like you have but people around you or
like by the time your face is on the
train you shouldn't you not have train
driver yeah I literally stand next to it
all day yes and you often comes back
yeah it's amazing yeah the one time I
did it was really fun it was I was with
you i think yamaneika and sherrod and
myself i think it was that I don't
remember but it was it was a fun show
man yeah it was you sure Arden yeah that
was a good a SEPA so it's a lot of work
though that's your writing yeah it's a
long day you've been writing into it
explain the show yeah well you know
you're getting topics and you kind of
just you slamming each other and there's
different segments it's not it's not
just one like at midnight you would kind
of just go through right but this has
different segments and then there's like
well if you make it to the finals and
you slam each other and that's making
fun
the internet making fun of each other
it's sort of like it has like a roast
Baddeley type of element to it but then
it has sort of an @midnight II type of
element where you're [ __ ] with the
internet and but it is a lot of work
it's like it's a co-writing packet it's
also get to a writing packet when you
get hired for it but it's fun it really
is because you bringing a buddy you hang
out all day the writers come in and help
you out you shoot the [ __ ] and disappear
some pizza to the crowd plays the pieces
of the crowd the crowd be lit but after
the bass a pizza uh-huh it's fun once
you get to figure out who's the best
like all around yeah calming you don't
immediately you're hitting all those
different specialties that's true right
so did you win your episode Jim I did
yeah
I think so it was between myself and
yamaneika Jim is a beast when it comes
to competition like I've seen him do at
midnight I've been out in LA when he
does have midnight and he just wins
every single night just came super
prepared I remember that yeah it was it
was not a game you have to prepare you
have to some people don't some people
can wing it so people think they could
wig in a day they crash winging is not
as not as easy as you think because you
literally are you're responding
immediately to a line and to a moment
and it goes very quickly when five guys
and three guys are trying to weigh in on
something you have to kind of have an
idea because we're all funny people so
it's not like you're improving with a
[ __ ] librarian and a desk clerk yes
two other comedians MyGateway Dominique
as well me big J yeah I mean he could do
it together and yamaneika winged it and
but that's like her personality time
yeah like she will just come in and
she's just a big loud funny woman and
she's gonna make everybody laugh period
but I think you had the crowd has to be
rooting for you to wing it right if you
like I'm a likeable [ __ ] like if I
get angry what'd you say I got your back
DK unlikable unlit oh yeah you got to be
prepared and win the motor yeah yeah but
it's really fun a really fun show I
enjoyed doing it Damien it was a good
time I'm glad it was a good time it was
a good time when you own that was fun
and it's weird too cos when you're doing
it like we're talking about Roseanne
this morning you're as comedians we're
we just do jokes I mean some are [ __ ]
tasteless some are not and when you do
it you got that many comics on every
show doing that many jokes in a row it's
like the odds are somebody is gonna say
something oh you're gonna upset somebody
yeah so you always have to worry about
like alright is this going to go out and
then the tone changes we've already
taped the show
then that joke gets us acts it's fights
it's really weird with jokes now you
gotta worry about every joke yeah it
seems like it well that's the other
problem people on TV is they're like
they're afraid of losing their job so
it's not even like everyone's a [ __ ]
and everyone's PC nobody really is
behind closed doors nobody has these
words right what happens is you have a
hundred people that work out a network
there's but everyone's got a boss and
then they go yeah dude some dumb joke
some monkey joke is gonna get me fired
[ __ ] that dude and then they say
everything's off-limits and they keep it
super safe and then you know you just
realize TV has sort of become a safe
platform but it will say comedy knockout
they gave us no censorship at all they
didn't give us any restrictions and we
went [ __ ] dark it was me big J I'm
Anika and it was very it was like such a
really fun it was a fun show such a
great experience and I appreciated the
fact that truTV allowed us to go really
dark finish it we did and we did all
really you know racial jokes said
parents everything it was great it was
real it was good I mean you know I
always ask people sometimes we bug out
just at the table just sitting around
ask questions to say you're like how
much money would it take you to fully
speak your opinion 100% at all times
I'll do it for a dollar one dollar the
committee who thinks he's a rebel it's
not about being PC it's not about whoa I
don't it's about like yeah they will
[ __ ] fire I'm fireable I am bendable
you have one day where it's liar liar
but you're in the industry you have to
say the truth to everybody you [ __ ]
me I would be great though because I
would just praise them and then they
remember like what this guy told the
truth of [ __ ] freshman sweet guy
nice this guy it was a really good guy
you know we are though getting to a
place in culture where we won't have to
worry about it as much because racism is
going away her Starbucks is getting rid
of racism yeah together I don't know
about you so go to coffee I learned I
learned a lot from the Starbucks video
did you guys watch it oh it was closed
yesterday I saw that video they closed
for the afternoon were helpful so that
all eight thousand stores closed for the
afternoon
so that all how many Starbucks there are
they close 8,000 stores in the afternoon
first of all it so it's very telling
them they didn't do it all day because
they still want that coffee money in the
morning yeah I mean they can't be crazy
right but they closed it so that all the
employees could go to racial sensitivity
training in that way yeah Starbucks was
racing special sensitivity training has
changed in the past thirty years when
the first star works first opened up it
was a different racial sensitivity I
mean it was well yes Starbucks has been
racist this whole time yeah and as of
today you know let's mark this date down
owner accounts not racist I mean it's
very important to uh I learned a lot
from them I didn't think I could buy
which I remain teachable right well I
always thought you were very woken Wells
Amaya and that's awake oh whoa oh yeah
that's right
but as it turns out no we all we all
could learn along there's always
something to be learned I won't go to
Starbucks anymore but they're not racist
anymore no bathrooms available hmm
that's true people are shooting up not
waiting on [ __ ] line for some drug
addict homeless person to use the
bathroom about should have looked at any
of the Wi-Fi stations on corn the
corners in New York City we get a free
phone call on internet and Sue's camping
out in front of it oh my god people
every single one you pass it's a guy
sleeping with a USB wire running down in
the side yeah that's Starbucks now
they're morons they are it is so stupid
stupid thing it is different that's
right
a long inclusive it is inclusive you
don't have to buy anything what [ __ ]
store says come in if you're not a
customer new policies anybody gives the
bathroom your customers soon as you walk
in the door you're not to spend any
money because they got they got spooked
she did it on personal no I did not
recognizing you the CEO you could go oh
god this [ __ ] Seattle dope so yeah
just flying like a [ __ ] on a video if
you're a man you stare at a camera and
cry because of your employees being
racially insensitive okay crying going
on yeah I didn't seem
he had water in his eyes enn and going I
mean I just can't believe that I've
created a culture where we wouldn't let
them homeless people interviews our
bathrooms after that's crazy
business yeah that's what it is right a
business you dumb [ __ ] and you
can charge the homeless guy a dollar for
a coffee you can use the bathroom that
is the way it is the business also if
you go to the hood if you go to Harlem
right where I live and you want do a
black owned business and you try to use
the bathroom
they will SiC dogs on you or do your
mind that allowed to [ __ ] walk into
these awesome bike hey I was going to
use your bathroom right now and [ __ ] all
over your stuff you got to use trickery
yeah I mean that's that's part of living
in the city is learning how to use the
public force right that's right I mean I
walk into a place like sorry I'm late oh
yeah and I'll just run and use the
toilet that's right yeah I know what
I'll do is I'll actually go get a table
at a restaurant that's what I do I
literally will check in but the
restaurants say you want to get a table
and then go to Bethany up you know what
yeah I don't really I swear to [ __ ]
god I do that that's deep couldn't you
just go like I'm going to meet a friend
and then you walk right back to the
bathroom you in here so you at the spot
I did it I'll go to like the bar and go
do you have a bathroom in here and
they're like it's for customers only I
go yeah obviously I'm gonna order a
drink but is there nothing back here oh
yeah walk right out it's better than
walking into a hotel lobby like a
five-star hotel lobby
yeah and you get into the bathroom and
it's a full door like it's not even a
stall it's a full door you can [ __ ] in
peace for an hour
email I also I'm an equinox member so I
could have a nice bathroom or thing I've
jumped in there and taken some shits and
[ __ ] [ __ ] scrammed guests Digital
doing pretty well Equinox okay we see
the guy crying I haven't seen that well
this is right after Johnson Kevin
Johnson right after the incident in
Philly yeah where the black guys got
arrested for sitting in the Starbucks
and then he went on TV well not a rest
first in Starbucks arrested for being
asked to leave the Starbucks and then
the cops came is that are you guys gonna
leave and then what no we're not
yeah and then they got arrested and for
not ordering something that's more of an
accurate representation of the story
yeah everyone should have to order
something in a store when you're there I
don't care who you are you should be
forced to what they have is a little
something they said the employee didn't
handle it well but I don't know what the
employee was supposed to do it to people
with to cuff you can't even if they were
just too old asian lady you can't
physically throw the people out and
start they said that I think the guy's
got in there like 1135 cops was caught
by 1137 like amor like give me a little
sound at least like I'm about here or
let me get me and people do just sit in
Starbucks like hang out and wait for
people it's not you don't need to call
the police I'd like I'd like to see how
much truth is to that that 11:35 they
walked in and it was a little at 7:00 I
don't believe that mmm I just don't
believe that because it's very easy
amping out I know I think that they sat
down they were hanging out like a lot of
people do and then eventually no here's
what he actually happened because this
is from their account so I don't know if
this happened in two minutes but they
were there then they got up and said hey
can I use the bathroom
mm-hmm and then the woman said well no
it's only for employees you need a code
and then they sat back down and they
were hanging out a little while longer
and then they said watching guys we need
the tables only for employees and then
they said well not we're not leaving and
at that point it became they were
waiting what you call the 9-1-1 call you
know the hey we're not leaving he said
we're waiting for a friend who got a
meeting coming and then the guy showed
up yeah the guy's like what are you guys
doing why you why are you arresting
these guys they were here for a meeting
we're Arthur said that's fine yes that
happened um
but regardless if they asked you to
leave if somebody asked me to leave a
store I leave and if I don't leave I
expect the cops to get called on me it's
as simple as that I mean I don't really
know what are the way to put it you know
it also depends though like if you just
sitting there not doing anything wrong
you're legitimately waiting and you're
like I've been here for three minutes
right and they call the cops it's a bit
of a reaction yeah then again if you
don't call the cops what the [ __ ] do you
do because if you want someone to leave
you can't just grab them by the [ __ ]
discover there I can toss them hmm sure
it's tough you could do
kick get on TV and cry about it Kevin
Johnson yeah I don't know if it's a if
you're exhausted or if you know how this
really affected you maybe it's a
combination
but you seem to be really affected by
this what's going through your head well
you know oh no no it's been an emotional
experience oh came from acting class and
spending these three days on the ground
and and sitting across from these young
men and really were trying to understand
how he prominent ground on the ground
you like they're like they're the troops
like he's coming seeing what what the
author of black people chairs this or
books on the ground thank God for these
classes this is how out of touch Peter
CEOs like this is his idea of really
getting in touches talking there's two
guys like I actually spoke to some
regular right I got and that's rephrase
it I got down on the ground yeah and
talk to people do you see the next day
after this happened that they had the
fake coupon that was going around it was
very funny for funny it was hilarity
were going in there like yeah stop by on
worldstar a black dude is like Starbucks
is racist as the [ __ ] they
giving us free coffee she was terrified
he's like you know you doing that
reparations coffee I didn't hear about
that bug I'm here for my reparations
outta here 17 June all right hey the guy
to cross somehow that's right by any
means I'm also I'm all for that
I'm all for scamming them I'm all for
using the bathroom and not buying
anything
it's a reparation I'm all for look let
me tell you something my order on the
Starbucks app okay well they've never
checked my name lovers the equinox and
then it's great god I used to accept and
they've never checked my name a single
time when I've walked up to pick up my
coffee so just so everyone knows that
you look like a [ __ ] busy you can go
in and you can just steal a coffee right
now everybody I won't should go do this
I wonder who's here to pick up the
coffee labels Puerto Rican rattles
but the point is I don't give a [ __ ]
about Starbucks at all I'm just saying
like you never have a real conversation
and behind closed doors everyone goes
okay well yeah if I owned a business I
wouldn't want people to come in and just
be able to use that business I do want a
business I don't give a [ __ ] what color
you are you're not walking into my
business and using my bathroom suck a
[ __ ] dick you give me Chinese black
[ __ ] Indian I can't use the gas
digital bathroom you you're white but
all those other ones cannot that's the
boy yes white is alright the rest yeah
how dark do you like your coffee wink
wink right I get it I get it
I'm gonna see more of those gentlemen
crying really getting to me
yes this is good stuff I'm like it's a
scene from Barry from these young men
and really trying to understand how this
could happen in today's society in a
Starbucks in our box Starbucks where our
mission is around the human experience
what it's caught by the [ __ ] eating a
war it's coffee these that the human
experience
it's coffee heightened sense of self
important oh my god it's the human
experience this beans and it's coffee
and it makes me [ __ ] that's what you
sell [ __ ] inducing beverage the Ellis
Island of caffeine the human experience
it's so silly to be here's the standard
right you don't want people who can't
afford a coffee in your business right
that's just a minimum it's two dollars
and fifty cents if you can't afford a
coffee I don't really want your
patronage period just a I'm a business
owner it's just not really worth it for
me to even have a conversation with you
so that should be the bare minimum you
have a [ __ ] coffee shop G show you
you are advocating for the CEO of
Starbucks to go on the news and be like
look if you can't afford coffee [ __ ] out
of here you're goddamn right I really
would appreciate it more because that's
what he's probably saying behind closed
doors well you know what behind he's
probably this guy behind closed like
he's really an out-of-touch guy exactly
who thinks that this was an active overt
hatred by his employee and it's like no
it was just somebody who's innocent
didn't handle it well they didn't hand
my situation well but did you hear that
I'm
uncle I did not know great that wasn't
what she sounded very panic scream I
read it I don't that they maybe they do
but I definitely read the transcript
yeah and it was like she was like yeah
I've asked them to leave they refused
gentlemen oh my Cathy they're refusing
to make a purchase or leave
I know Starbucks eight events free you
can employ one of those things where I
asked him to make a purchase they'll
make a purchase I asked him leave they
won't leave now what like I I know that
guy I was that [ __ ] punk-ass kid who
was like yeah make me make me leave and
then I sit there and that's what [ __ ]
happened here anybody who I don't give a
[ __ ] what business mean you're showing
up for you're refusing to leave a
Starbucks when this tiny [ __ ] idiot
[ __ ] manager is coming excuse me can
you make a purchase or leave and you're
gonna sorry make me leave I don't want
to be in business with that person I can
[ __ ] what business meeting you're going
to you're not acting appropriately for
society that's not the way people
[ __ ] act and I've been kicked out of
places I've been arrested I've been put
in cuffs
I've been I've been a victim of racism I
believe me all that [ __ ] I grew up in a
[ __ ] white trash neighborhood where I
was called the n-word every single day
of my life okay but when I left the
house but I mean people have personal
responsibility accountability it is
there's no if you let's say go to a
restaurant you get a table and you sit
down sometimes you sit for a few minutes
before you make an order because you're
waiting for the third person in your
party right
you don't always order if this was like
a half hour but I think it was faster
than that or forty minutes but when it
comes to like you want to a restaurant
you're waiting for your third person a
lot of times people yeah we're just
waiting for someone to come okay if you
just made it sound like him getting
called the n-word growing up is the same
as black people getting called the
n-word which is not the case the kind of
is I don't want to say I'm I'm Brown
being called the n-word for the same
exact reason that was the intent of it
but day was saying it reluctantly like
they were getting into uber they were
like
[Laughter]
you have to if you went to a restaurant
right now and asked to be seated at a
table right and they said hey we don't
see people into there your entire entire
parties here which a lot that's a lot of
rest a lot of places you don't go would
stay in the restaurant I you just don't
sit down
he didn't sit down but so if Starbucks
says he unfortunately you can't use the
bathroom until you purchase something
you get a receipt that's their policy as
if I don't give a [ __ ] if the policies
just to stand on one foot and jump up
and down and clap your hands don't use
that [ __ ] restaurant don't go to
Starbucks anymore if that's the policy
you don't agree with it the problem
business owners that arrested the
problem they wouldn't leave if he means
the other guy there was another guy who
a black guy who was videoing and he
showed a white guy and he goes so you
just used their bathroom and make a
purchase yet and the guy was like no not
yet but he's gonna make it and then with
him when the black I went to ask she was
like you're not a customer you can't so
she basically said to the white guy like
yes I believe you'll make the purchase
this guy she was like I'm gonna based
off of what I know video it's not video
and her reaction was kinda like yeah and
that came right after this so it was
like two in a row they were like it was
yeah it was like a prove-it double
standard and show me show me that show
me that video cuz I don't know what
video talking about I really don't I
don't know if we know that yeah you say
black guy bathroom Starbucks yeah I
didn't I didn't see that video and I
mean what do you me to say look it's
this is the reality we walk down the
street people look at me differently
than they look at Jim it's a fact right
if I'm walking down the dark alleyway
and Jim is people are gonna cross the
[ __ ] stream when I'm walking by and
they're not gonna do in Jim because I'm
a big poor tariqa guy I got tattoos I'm
gonna timid ating looking dude it is
what it is that society you know so yeah
is that unfair a hundred percent but
that's not really what the issue is they
weren't making a station mm were they
making a saying because they knew they
were gonna let some white guy use the
bathroom and so you know what I'm sick
of this I'm with this is the time
there's profiling just like how you said
somebody's horse
to you differently because you look
different from Jim yeah you know it you
accept that you say [ __ ] I'll just
take that's reality that's reality
I choose though you could change that
reality because the reality right and
when they asked me to leave going you
know it actually I'm better miss I'm
gonna go across the street I'm gonna use
your competitor that would be showing
them not standing there going you know
what no I'm not going to leave make me
leave that's that's that's perpetuating
the saying here say they never said make
me leave they didn't send me the rest it
was two real estate guys right there
wearing well fair enough
if I showed up at a [ __ ] it for a real
estate meeting and some dudes were in
sweatpants and a do-rag
I'm sorry I swear to look at it go to
the bathroom video we're all over the
place what area do I swear to God look
at the bathroom video
[Music]
okay filming the toilet outside I love
it look he's not doing that here yeah
that's better you're live now he's
trying to wait for this guy to walk out
of the bathroom this is like when TMZ
catcher at the airport yeah I've never
seen this from the beginning I hope this
guy's not dropping a deuce he comes okay
arms getting tired
look at this guy's [ __ ] are you telling
me that that this same Starbucks has
never let a black person so it's silly
it's a very silly thing you can sit
there with a camera I promise you I
considered any song that just disproves
your first perk employers prove anything
that racial profiling exists it 100%
exists that does that does prove
anything I guess an asset of a Starbucks
right now
you just said go by cetera flex policy
and we're saying the video right there
shows them not going by that this came
right after that arrest so it's
embarrassing so no that's different
seventeen-year-old kids this is stupid
yes I can also create a video right now
and go to Starbucks and show you a
hundred people using a bathroom without
making a purchase before that policy
came into effect it's very easy to set
this up and go yes this is a thing it's
not even the same Starbucks I thought
that this was the same store but ten
minutes later that's in my opinion that
would be damning up like damn do that
same chick the same management is worse
now it's a Starbucks issue instead of an
issue with the one right now you're
looking at like always this and again we
all know that the Starbucks on a racist
company but when it's on video like this
and the guy who a person did their job
and one person did the guy is saying did
he let you use the bathroom yes they let
me use the bathroom with the code and
the black guy is going they didn't let
me and then he calls the manager out I
get what that is she maybe she knows
this guy maybe she doesn't
but the bacilli embarrass is something
the person making right
they're embarrassed embarrassed the
bottom line is as a company it's
embarrassing after this arrest happens
and then this video comes out right
after what I would say what I would say
is the person in Philadelphia actually
did their job correctly because we're
not supposed to let people use the
bathroom
this manager did not do the drop
rightfully the bathroom in Philadelphia
I'm talking about the other one it
wasn't the bathroom that wasn't a
bathroom it was that was them just
sitting at a table they asked to use the
bathroom initially that's why the
manager even came up to them was because
they asked to use the bathroom first and
they said we have to make a purchase
then they sat down and then they said
well guys you can't use you can't sit
here until you make a purchase I don't
know if the [ __ ] happened this might
have been a mere oysters manager
screaming the n-word I'm just saying you
look at the [ __ ] facts here it's not
that's I don't think that's embarrassing
that's no more damning or embarrassing
than anything else company that's a
human sort of it's humiliating the CEOs
crying on [ __ ] video going oh I can't
believe that our company's doing this
it's [ __ ] it's it's a silly silly
thing and the entire thing is sort of
it's just created because this is the
type of environment that we have where
people love racism people love with you
the chief and there's a million people
2.1 nine million people see in this
video and you're in your company it's
not about what's right wrong it's
embarrassing because it's like two
million people have seen this what
people will say is a very obvious
example of one guy being giving
favoritism for another guy so if you're
running that company like two [ __ ]
million people saw this one incident on
the heels
it looked immediate runs with what they
run right but on the other thing two in
a row in a week it's embarrassing as a
company you panic and they [ __ ] panic
and I didn't handle it well all these
people would probably have issue with
you kind of not minding racial profiling
at all like they're they're all saying
no it's not minding me official profile
it's part of life to sit here and go
people aren't gonna be racially profiled
that I'm not gonna be racially profiled
as a Puerto Rican guy that's silly for
me to go well kumbaya we I need to
timoshev cause not gonna happen right if
you were calling people out on it and I
was like Louis yeah its racial profiling
if I was going to microaggressions all
day long I'd be some [ __ ] [ __ ]
feminists liberal kid who's actually not
doing anything to create a better world
I got a [ __ ] Puerto Rican
that I raised to be a good person I'm
doing more for society than going and
posting [ __ ] on Twitter or or or or
pretending that these are a real this is
real social you can do both things yeah
you got I'm not about smoothies these
are social justice word but this video
was embarrassing for start it's
embarrassing when the guy is saying did
they let you use the bathroom before
purchase yeah they just gave me the code
well you didn't give me the code as a
company it's hard to take that obvious
example even if they haven't skipped a
beat I guarantee you they haven't
dropped a percentage point you can not
lately they've lost every time well let
me actually he got less rights than
white kids no but I'm teaching my Puerto
Rican son to understand that in society
people are gonna look at him differently
than they look at white kids and even
did you use that it needs to understand
that and not let that be a deterrent
it's dude you have cards that you can
[ __ ] play or not right so it is what
it is so I'm not gonna sit here and go
like oh well you know what gyms you have
less opportunities because you're brown
and sorry that's just life that's not
the attitude I have but it is it is a
fact that he is brown and that there are
things that people gonna look at him
differently and for me to ignore that I
think it's silly so you accept like
different behavior just because you're
brown you accept you've you've said you
know what that's the reality of life it
is what it is I accepted I'm not gonna
fight against it I'm not gonna protest
about I'm not gonna make little
microaggressions I'm just gonna take
this el and eat it and I'm gonna be
truthful now no no yes I think you know
it's taking with W because I'm not
losing I don't give up because I'm brown
I'm not going like Oh unless then no
you're right I have personally been told
not to use the bathroom if I have been
told plenty of times I cannot use the
bathroom now in my mind is there maybe a
white person that came in and asked to
use about them they let them probably
it's probably happened am i learning
establishment is this by the way am i
spending any time thinking about this am
i spending any time putting any mental
energy or effort into changing that no
but if you had if you had an example
right after imagine if you would get a
gig and you saw the [ __ ] Club owner
came up to you and said hey man stay
away from any of that race
stuff I don't like it you know it's not
good for the club and then you overheard
him telling a white comic that racial
stuff was really good it was really
smart you wouldn't just take that you'd
be like you [ __ ] that of course
because it's a double standard and it's
an obvious in that moment even if he had
another reason you're looking at it like
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you would not
take that I wouldn't get arrested I
wouldn't not even you would get arrested
I'm this guy yeah through video we
talked I was pissed off at the double
standard about one guy being given the
code and he asked the same question it
wasn't given the code and I'm saying as
it likes to say his comics if they said
hey man don't do that racial stuff it's
a little too tough for the audience and
then you overheard him telling a white
comic in the greenroom the racial stuff
really good yeah whole standard context
it would annoy me and I would say
something and I'm not arguing that you
can't have a right to say something the
people are sharing it or it's just
clickbait this guy sure even from his
perspective I'm sure he believes he's
doing something truly good but it's
[ __ ] it's just not real I'm saying
the story here isn't a real story it
happened you're right sue the the vert
with this story is articulating is that
Starbucks lets white people use their
bathroom and they don't let black people
use matter let now let singular no no
it's not about the company it's just an
embarrassing thing when two [ __ ]
different stores have two incidents in a
row and both are on video it's
embarrassing for everyone Donuts I asked
for a breve latte which is a lot to me
with half and half and one Dunkin Donuts
will say oh we don't do that we don't
have an option to do it on our keyboard
I can only put in was on my keyboard and
then the next time Donuts goes yeah sure
who gives a [ __ ] because somebody's not
doing the job okay how about if you saw
all right you saw a white customer asked
for that drink and they're like well I'm
not supposed to but I'll do it and then
you ask for that drink and they go no
don't tell me you wouldn't really go
there anymore I would make a video I
wouldn't go there anymore I'm like witty
man [ __ ]
why do you guys think you're like
getting me in some argument here what is
the point that I'm wrong about here
right just as angry as this guy and this
guy had a legitimate reason to be pissed
off and it is embarrassing
my mother star piece of [ __ ] are you
guys holding your standard by what I
would do I've been kicked out of places
for threatening violence and it's it's
like I hate political correctness but
when they get caught like that I don't
think the whole company it's
embarrassing and Louis nobody's trying
to get you nobody started arguing before
you know your guys doing
you were you you were the one that got
all hot and started policy now I support
them right it works both ways
right no I just feel like this it can be
good average absolutely yeah I just feel
like maybe my argument is getting away
from me here because I don't really
understand how you guys think you're
right about anything I said I think
we're 20 minutes past that yeah I I
really don't even know I feel anguish no
problem with arguing nobody thinks that
the other buddy listens all we do is Yap
and nobody listens and the thing is I
don't like being PC Starbucks had that
embarrassing incident in Philly two cops
or caucus to [ __ ] dumb guys won't
leave and then this bathroom thing with
a guy he asks the guy what happened I
don't think it's an embarrassing
incident you doing before we get into
Philly and everything I think I know how
to bring us back to a place where we're
all on the same page I think we should
watch some of I don't dis examine the
racists you know the racial training
video that Starbucks showed is what it
was yesterday yes really help we have
the first five minutes I learned a lot I
feel like if we all watch this and look
at this we have a rainbow coalition here
at the table that is true you know this
is this is great we did this up Jim's
gay we did that's obvious so we didn't
mean I'm not part of the rainbow we
assembled this panel on purpose Troy
what we would like to see is the ratio
there it is the racial bias video let's
all learn yeah so we can all learn
together thank you
without a doubt the events in
Philadelphia prompted us to bring a
thousand stores yes and a hundred and
some new rags and partners to be
partners where's the drag but first of
all those are [ __ ] sweatpants do we
correct your sorry reg who's the guy in
the back is the guy by the way they're
nice they're not they're not they're not
old sweat pants either their expenses
hold on how does he keep those braids in
place what he thinks in his pocket now
your general yeah for the record they
went from being guys in do-rag saying
make me he's wearing sweat pants and
he's got [ __ ] cornrows he's going for
a business meeting and sweat pants
that's crazy I go for interview he's
meeting he might already know yeah I
don't show up on the radio and the
business meeting by the way who knows
they may know each other they may have
done business before may just be a guy
they're already in the middle of a deal
with are you guys pretending that they
were really showing up for a business
meeting that this is real what the [ __ ]
is going on right now there were two
dudes who didn't want to leave and said
make me [ __ ] leave that's what happen
I don't believe the guy was even real I
believe another guy showed up and said
hey you know yeah I was meeting them
some [ __ ] white now some [ __ ] yes
I think you're reaching or anything I
think some white knight [ __ ] showed up
and said you know what I was here to
meet them yes I'm the one who agenda
what's my agenda Brown Sam the [ __ ]
program I'm Brown
from a real perspective not some fun
this is some crazy yeah here's the real
perspective the guy really did show up
he really was supposed to meet them they
really were just meeting there and the
guys like what are you what the [ __ ] you
doing like it was genuine shock too they
were arresting these guys they didn't go
into Starbucks just a loiter they didn't
go in a lawyer there were two guys
there's some kind of real estate do you
have a [ __ ] real estate man buy a
coffee I just want to tell you maybe
they were waiting for the guy maybe they
were even whatever but how did you
flip-flop during the show you literally
said you gotta buy a coffees we go into
a place and now you're going well they
said nah so saying you don't have to buy
a coffee what I'm saying is they had
only been there for a couple of minutes
and they were legitimate way for
somebody and I also said a minute ago
that a lot of times you do go into a
restaurant and you sit for a few minutes
before you make your order waiting for
your party this is a coffee shop online
and nobody sends me a leave which is
very nice nobody said make me leave and
nobody had on do-rags I think mr.
flip-flop of course you should be able
to you should be forced to make a
purchase in a straitness a do-rag but
I'm looking at a picture of a guy in
cornrows and sweatpants what you want me
to say here there's no shot clock in
Starbucks a minute yeah I didn't flip
flop it's the same point of view I had
this thing if you're gonna make that
policy because people do go in there and
do a McDonald's right and you're meeting
somebody there I would say be perfectly
normal to sit down at a table wait until
you meet the guy there then the two of
you go up to the counter and get your
meal cuz you're gonna eat at the same
time is that crazy
sure if that guy was coming in a few
minutes hey he's gonna be here in five
minutes or ten minutes and then we'll
order something or whatever but here's
the thing right none of us know really
what happened during that whole scenario
right everyone sitting we know we know
they didn't have on dewer I know but you
don't know the pittance by the way
behind one one powers of deduction here
let's just look at society and go why
would this woman why would would this
woman call the cops at that point what
do you think the tone was she's in
Philadelphia Philadelphia there's
probably incidents in that Starbucks and
she has said there's been instance that
Starbucks so she was a little bit
probably nervous
she'd asked the guys to leave they said
they're waiting for somebody didn't want
to leave my the way horn was completely
I'm sorry miss which being arrest order
we're gonna order we're gonna order
coffee in a minute well you've gotten
arrested for like aggressive behavior do
you get arrested calmly and being like I
am kind of confused as to why this is
happening or do you still have
aggression and all the people around
them by the way let me calm down
the people around the home okay I just
worry about every time I've been
arrested I calm the [ __ ] down this is a
guy with a gun they're mentally put up
around them we're all going what the
[ __ ] they're not all white knights the
people around them are going they didn't
do anything that all around them were
shocked at the boys sure okay what do
you want me to say if we leave or you
should leave we're using our powers of
deduction as well I'm watching when I
started the video and what people have
said about it I heard the 9-1-1 call it
wasn't a panic than i went one call no
not at all it wasn't these guys are
about to be violent and of course make
me results in a nine one one call that
involves somebody she hora cops time out
she's gonna have to call the cops the
whole day she didn't have to call the
cops but then again I don't even mind
her calling the cops if you want people
to leave it I'll even what do you do you
can't throw them out right it was just
kind of handled poorly